Hello, class. This
lecture will focus
on antidepressants
and mood stabilizers.
So in this lecture,
I will describe the
hypothesis for depression,
and I will go through
the various groups
of antidepressants.
I will consider their
mechanisms, their
adverse effects, drug
interactions. I will also
include some of the
newer drug approvals.
I will also talk
about bipolar disorder
and their specific
treatments and then I will
talk a little bit
about lithium and its
adverse effects and
lithium is one of the
drugs used for bipolar
disorder I will say
that these two
lectures this one and
lecture 87 which is known
as the antipsychotics
there will be a
good amount of drugs
that we will need to
cover so the lecture
will be somewhat a
little bit longer. But
it's very important
because these drugs are
not only tested on
boards, they're going
to be very relevant
to clinical practice.
I will be doing question
reviews for both of them.
If you want to
review these drugs a
little bit more
in depth, please
let me know and I
can meet with you.
So I will begin with
the amine hypothesis.
And this is where
we kind of go into
why do we use
these drugs for
depression? Well,
the first thing is
reserpine. This
was a drug used for
hypertension probably
many years ago.
We have newer drugs
now. Of course,
we have ACE inhibitors.
We have ARBs,
beta blockers,
calcium channel
blockers. But before
we had those drugs,
we had reserpine.
And reserpine
was a drug that
would deplete
neurotransmitters,
dopamine,
norepinephrine, and
serotonin. And that was
very important because
depleting norepinephrine
would mean that
there's not enough
of this transmitter to
go to the alpha receptors
of the vessels and
cause contraction.
So if that wasn't
happening, yes, the
patient's blood
pressure would go down.
But the thing to
know is that the loss
of these neurotransmitters
did contribute
to the patient
feeling depressed.
Many of the drugs
that treat depression,
in fact, raise these
neurotransmitters.
Either they do
something to the
receptor, they act
as partial agonist,
antagonist, or even
reuptake inhibitors
like the SSRIs. And
these drugs are used
commonly for depression.
So again, it's
all around raising
neurotransmitter.
The other thing is
that beta blockers,
especially the
ones that are
lipophilic and cross
the blood-brain
barrier, can affect
a patient's mood.
That's one thing to
know. And the same
thing with alpha-2
agonist. Because remember
alpha-2 agonists
do work centrally
they work presynaptically
and they're
decreasing sympathetic
overdrive which again
means that there's
less norepinephrine
and that is
appropriate again for
decreasing blood pressure
and heart rate but
it will increase the
risk of depression
and then some other
things to know that
steroids and anybody
with increased cortisol
can have changes in
mood and that's going
to be true also of
using glucocorticoids
estrogen and testosterone
deficiency have
increased depression
and that makes sense
because if you think
about postpartum
depression, and you
think about even patients
in menopause, you
know that the change
in estrogen can result
in changes in mood.
Patients that
are hypothyroid
can be more depressed.
And the other thing
is that any atrophy in
the hippocampus and
cortex are also associated
with depression. So
in patients that have
early AD or even
Parkinson's or some of the
neurodegenerative
diseases, as these
areas get more
atrophied, there's going
to be also a greater
risk of depression.
And we know that's
definitely true.
Changes in mood comes
with a lot of these
neurodegenerative
disorders. And then we
have to define
unipolar versus bipolar
depression. So So unipolar
is really a simple
way of saying major
depressive disorder.
Bipolar is a
combination of both.
There's some periods
of depressive mood
and there's some
periods of manic mood.
So the antidepressants
are going
to come in a
couple of groups.
The first discovered
are going to be the
monoamine oxidase inhibitors.
And I will discuss
this pretty much at
length, even though
there is not much
relevance for them anymore,
given their drug
interactions, it's very
important to understand
this for your exams.
And the other thing
with monoamine oxidase
inhibitors, we did
go through monoamine
oxidase B, and that
was a drug like
selegiline, and that
was specific for
dopamine. And I did
mention that that effect
on dopamine, raising
dopamine levels,
would actually be a
therapeutic for those
patients who have
Parkinson's disease.
So I already introduced
this concept.
We have tricyclics
and we have the
SSRIs. And right
now, for many
of these depressive
disorders, post
-traumatic stress
disorder, OCD,
some of the effects
that happen with eating
disorders, SSRIs are
usually going to be
first line okay for
now it could change in
the future because we
have many new drugs
coming to market and
that's true atypical
antidepressants and
the newer agents are
starting to get very
popular and they also have
some less side effects
than the SSRIs and
then S-ketamine is
used for treatment
-resistant depression. And
this is an NMDA receptor
blocker for
glutamate. And by that
blockade, there's going
to be some increase in
glutamate. And that
increase in glutamate
has been shown to
be very effective at
treating these refractory
cases of depression.
But with this S-ketamine,
just like the name
says, it is the S
-enantiomer of ketamine,
and ketamine is, in
fact, an illicit drug.
So we'll talk about
that in the lecture.
One thing that's
common to, especially
the first four groups,
is that they do
have some time to
get a benefit. it.
And that's pretty
standard because it takes
a while for the
brain now to adapt to
the changes in
neurotransmitters. And
because of that,
especially in adolescents,
you're going to see
that many of these
drugs have a black box
warning for suicide.
So that would mean
that in the first weeks
of giving these
medications, it's
probably a good idea
to combine the drug
therapy with maybe a CBT,
that they're actually
maybe talking to a
therapist so that
the therapist can
talk to them and see
how they're adjusting.
Okay, it also helps
the patient to kind
of talk things out.
You're going to
see that some
antidepressants, or I
should say some physicians,
will sometimes
want a washout
period. Meaning, you
stop one antidepressant,
and they might
wait a couple of
weeks before starting
a new medication.
And that's definitely
going to be true
for the MAOIs, and
I'll get to them in
a minute, because
there are various
side effects, especially
serotonin syndrome,
that can occur with
MAOIs if they're
given too closely,
say, to an SSRI.
but I will say that
presently there's
various ways we can do
that some physicians
will stop one
medication and the next
day start the next
some physicians may
wean the patient off
the first medication
and start the
second medication
gradually it's all
going to depend on the
patient the dose of
the medication, and
also the mechanism
of that medication.
And I will say that
when you're talking
about psychiatry,
with the training that
psychiatrists get,
they'll be able to really
pinpoint how they want
to do this. So it's
not something that
you're going to be
responsible at this
point in your training.
But if you do elect
psychiatry, you will be
very, very comfortable
with how to do this,
if you even consider
doing the washout.
Elderly is going to
be a concern because
some of the drugs that
we will discuss, like
the tricyclics, can
have a negative effect
on the heart. And also,
due to the fact that
those drugs block the
muscarinic receptors,
there can be some
changes in cognition.
And we also have to
be mindful with many
of these drugs, we
want to start at the
lowest dose because,
again, And with that
population, you will
get perhaps some degree
of dizziness. Some
of the drugs can
cause orthostatic
hypotension. And that can
mean that the patient
could end up falling.
So we need to be
very mindful of that.
Pregnancy, the
safest medications
are going to
be three SSRIs.
Fluoxetine, sertraline,
and citalopram. okay
so with pregnancy
and managing whether
it be bipolar or even
major depression disorder
you have to be very
um very um comfortable
with the literature
because some of the
drugs are going to be
an absolute no like
lithium and then we
cannot um we cannot
like forget about
other types of ways to
manage these disorders
psychotherapy is going
to be one of them and
I believe it's very
important that not
only are we giving
medication but the patient
is in fact having some
type of support and
to talk through some
of what may be happening
behind the scenes
and then electroconvulsive
therapy is
actually you know getting
a lot more emphasis
today in the past
especially with some of
the older movies they
would demonstrate people
getting ect and in
some ways it was not
ethical but i will say
that that's not the
case anymore i have
been told that many of
these instances is
really like a couple
of seconds where the
patient will get a a
shock but they don't
feel it so it's not you
know the way it was
portrayed in movies but
i'm that's not the
focus of the lecture.
So monoamine oxidase
inhibitors, remember
the ones that we're
going to talk about
today are the monoamine
oxidase A and those
are going to be for all
the neurotransmitters
and tyramine. The
ones that we discussed
in the Parkinson's
disease lecture were
the Mal-Bs and that
was going to be
specific for dopamine.
So by blocking that
enzyme you raise dopamine
levels and that was
effective as an
adjunct for Parkinson's
disease management.
So there's three, and
probably the phenylzine
is going to be the
one that is going to
be the most tested.
The use for monoamine
oxidase inhibitors
is for refractory
depression. So it's
going to be probably
the last on the list.
And that's because it
has certain drug and
food interactions.
And I will say in my
career of filling
prescriptions, I've only
had like two people
ever on fennelzine.
Okay, so you can
probably estimate that
the use of this is
very, very rare. But it
is a big tested concept.
So the idea here
is you can see that
you have precursors
now form neurotransmitters.
and now with
respect to what
would happen with a
monoamine oxidase
inhibitor they're going to
prevent the breakdown
so that more
neurotransmitter
norepinephrine, dopamine and
serotonin get to the
postsynaptic receptor.
But here's the thing
that tyramine is
contained in certain
foods and I like to think
of probably the wine
and cheese party where
patients will consume
a good amount of
cheese, they'll drink
wine, and say they were
taking a monoamine
oxidase inhibitor. The
issue is that if now
you cannot break down
tyramine because
you're blocking MAO-A,
what will happen
is that tyramine
now starts to,
how do I say,
kind of stay in inside
the synapse there's
going to be lots of
it and what ends up
happening is that
norepineprin is going to get
displaced into the
circulation and norepineprin
now will find the
vessels the alpha
receptors of of the
vessel and that's going
to cause a dangerous
increase in blood
pressure and that is
going to now present with
the patient even if they
never had hypertension
they're a young 30
year old patient
they're going to present
now to the ed with
a severe headache stiff
neck they're going
to have photosensitivity
and the other thing
is that they're going
to have a degree of
tachycardia and nausea
and vomiting and
this is what you called
hypertensive crisis
where the blood pressure
can go in the numbers
of 200 over 100
milligrams per mercury.
And what will happen
is that you have to
treat that very fast by
giving something like
phentolamine, which is
a non-selective alpha
blocker. okay so
that's why we don't use
these medications anymore
because classically
if they were given
and i go back to those
two patients that i
had on this phenolzine
they oftentimes had
to also have a list of
foods that had to
avoid so that could be
anything from red wine
to avocado soy sauce and
that can sometimes
be a problem not just
socially but there are
times you might forget
And that can lead to
the patient presenting
to the ED with this
hypertensive crisis.
The other thing is
if the patient is
taking anything
that increases
norepinephrine, like
a sympathomimetic.
So, for example, if
they had ADHD and
they were taking an
amphetamine, that
would be a problem.
If they were taking
cold medicine like
phenylephrine over-the
-counter, that also
would be a problem
with this whole story
of hypertension.
And then the other
thing is, this is where
the washout would be
especially critical.
Because with these drugs,
if they were taken,
say, now you needed
to change from a
serotonin reuptake
inhibitor to one of these,
you would run the risk
of getting serotonin
syndrome. So you have
to give a washout.
Same thing if the
patient was taking
meparidine for pain
or dextromethorphan,
the same thing
would ensue. So
you have to be
very careful
with starting
the malinhibitor
after the patient has
taken serotonin
type drugs.
So next we have
tricyclics. and they're
sometimes abbreviated
TCAs and this is
the list of them
and there's a couple
of of these drugs
that need to be
clarified because they
have specific uses.
So imipramine
in the past and maybe
some physicians can
use this for anuresis
and the classic story
is those children that
have this bedwetting
because this medication
group has a significant
degree of muscarinic
block. So if you're
giving this type of
medication, of course,
you're going to get
more of contraction of
the urinary bladder
and that would stop
urination. It makes
sense. but the issue is
that that's going
to open up more drug
interaction so as of as
of now we have a lot of
um physicians if you
have a a patient an
adolescent patient or a
pediatric patient that
has bedwetting we
tend to give now more
desmopressin and i'll
speak about that next year
disipramine is the
least anticholinergic
clomipramine has
been approved for OCD
that's the one that
would work best in
patients that have
that type of disorder
amitriptyline can be
used for certain pain
states whether it
be neuropathic or
migraine and I'll
explain that in a moment.
And then the last
one on the list is
amoxipine. So this
medication is nice because
it can be a way to
treat major depression,
but it has some blockade
of D2. So it can
be used in some
patients that had
schizophrenia or psychosis
because you're blocking
D2 in the mesolimbic
area. But again,
amoxipine would follow
the same group of
adverse effects,
especially if it blocks in
the nigrostriadium,
and that would be the
increase in Parkinson
-like symptoms like
rigidity and slowed
movements. So again,
next lecture, we'll talk
about antipsychotics
and blockade of D2,
but just understand
that anything that
blocks D2 is going to
present almost like
a Parkinson patient.
So tricyclics, how
they induce or they
prevent depression
or they treat is
that they're going
to block transporters
for norepinephrine
and serotonin. And
that's going to
inhibit the reuptake
because the principle
is that you want
to keep more of the
neurotransmitters
in the synapse to bind
to the postsynaptic
receptor like I
showed you early on
in that first slide
and that makes sense
but what happens
with tricyclics is
they have other
receptor blockades so if
they block the alpha
1 receptor you're
going to get orthostasis
if you block the
muscarinic receptor,
you're going to
get dryness,
constipation, tachycardia,
medriasis, H1 receptor
block. Again, we
can't negate the fact
that that can, number
one, cause weight
gain, and it can
also cause a degree
of drowsiness, which
may help in certain
patients. And I did
talk about this earlier
when we did sedative
hypnotics, that
there are certain
tricyclics that can be
used to induce sleep.
The other thing about
tricyclics is that
they do have cytochrome
P450 drug interactions.
And they are specific
for CYP2D6. There
are some patients
that are going to have
polymorphisms of this
isoenzyme. And should
that be true, you're
going to get more
of a reduced metabolism
of this drug,
and that's going to
lead to more toxicity.
Serotonin syndrome,
again, the idea here
is that they are
affecting the reuptake
of serotonin. So if
you gave a tricyclic
with, say, miperidine
or dextromethorphan
or with an SSRI, that
could be an issue.
And then the other
thing with tricyclics
is that when you overdose
on these medications,
this is going to
be very critical.
And there are the
three C's that you
have to remember.
They can cause coma,
they can cause
convulsions, and they
can cause cardiotoxicity.
So right now,
your knowledge of
cardiac is limited.
A quinidine is
a sodium channel
blocker, and you'll
see next year that
that is considered
to be one of the
drugs that we can
use for arrhythmia.
However, in an overdose,
what will happen,
because quinidine and
most of the sodium
channel blockers,
especially the 1A and the
1C, they're going to
block the sodium channel
so much in an overdose
that you're going
to get an increase in
QRS and an increase
in QT interval. And
that is probably due to
repolarization and
blocking the potassium
channel. And that can
cause an arrhythmia.
So if the patient
overdoses on a tricyclic,
you really need to
make sure that you give
them something that
is going to stabilize
those sodium channels.
And the antidote is
going to be for that
the sodium bicarbonate.
And again with
convulsions you need to
be very mindful of
what medication you
would give to stop
the seizures and you
would provide again
supportive therapy. But
tricyclics in an
overdose very critical
especially for the
heart and the brain.
So as you can see here
you're going to affect
the transporters
for serotonin and
norepinephrine. So you're
inhibiting reuptake.
So those are going
to stay here and bind
to their receptors.
And that makes sense.
That's the
antidepressant mechanism.
But then you're going
to have alpha block,
histamine block, and
muscarinic block. And
that's where the adverse
effects are going
to be especially
prominent with tricyclics.
So for a while,
these drugs were
used, but then
we went to the
SSRIs and I'll
explain in a moment.
So again, just to
go through serotonin
syndrome, this is
where there's two
serotonergic drugs
on board and the
patient will present
very early, probably
within 24 hours to
the ED and they're
going to have a
high temperature.
They're going to
be hypertensive,
tachycardic, so you are
affecting their
adrenergic system.
They're going to
have confusion and
delirium, and what's
going to stand
out is that they're
going to have
myoclonic effects, so
they're going to be
shaking and rigid,
having a seizure.
NMS is going to be
talked about in the next
lecture. there's
going to be succinct
differences between
the two because in some
ways they look the
same but they are very
different first of all
in drugs and mechanism
the way you treat
serotonin syndrome is
that you want to
provide supportive care
bentodiazepines
to stop the
myoclonus
that's happening
ciproheptadine and
the reason being is
that it blocks
serotonin receptors and
that makes sense
and you want to make
sure that you're
preserving the airway
and of course you're
going to watch
the heart rate and
blood pressure and
you'll decide on the
right medication.
So you'll see this picture
in the next lecture
and really what i
want to highlight is
that with nms the onset
is gradual serotonin
syndrome it happens
quickly nms classical
feature is lead pipe
rigidity here you're
going to have periods
of myoclonic episodes
and tremor and then of
course the drugs are
going to be different
anything that has an
effect on dopamine is
going to be nms and the
halogenated anesthetics
which I'll talk
about the ryanidine
receptor in that lecture.
And then, of course,
serotonin syndrome,
we're thinking about
two serotonergic drugs.
So before we do SSRIs,
it's a good idea to
go through the summary,
because you're going
to hear me say serotonin
1A and serotonin
2A throughout the
next few lectures. so
serotonin 1a actually
you may have
some recollection
of it because it
is g-inhibitory and
the drug that is most
associated with this is
going to be buspirone
and as you recall
buspirone was used for
anxiety it does have some
effects at improving
mood and there is
some degree of improving
cognition with this.
Because remember,
with buspirone,
there was some
effects on dopamine.
The serotonin 1B1D
that's also G-inhibitory
is going to be true of
the serotonin agonists.
And that's going
to be a drug like
sumatriptin that we use
for migraine headaches.
It's not going to be
covered here, but I
will talk about the
relationship between
serotonin and headache
in a few minutes.
Serotonin 2A, and
I'll say it in
the next lecture,
is GQ mediated. So
that has to do
with IP3 and DAG.
G inhibitory, remember,
was decreasing adenyl
cyclase. And an
agonist of serotonin 2a
is *** and that is an
illicit drug that can
induce symptoms of psychosis
because hallucinations
is common to those
that use *** the
blockers of that receptor
are going to be our
atypical antipsychotics
and to an extent
they also can be used
for bipolar depression
the serotonin 2C is also
GQ mediated so you're
thinking about IP3
and DAG and probably
locacerin it's not a
drug that we use anymore
because there has
been some reports of
increasing cancer risk
locacerin is a 2C agonist
and that medication
by being an agonist
was used for weight
loss you actually get a
reduction of appetite
but since it is it has
some effects at causing
cancer and we have
the glp1 drugs it's
not used anymore it's
off the market but it
is good to understand
this one because it
explains that when you
block that receptor with
say an atypical patients
will experience weight
gain even though
they're getting a
betterment of their mood,
the atypicals, and
you'll see it in the next
lecture, do cause
changes in metabolics,
weight gain, hyperglycemia,
hyperlipidemia.
And then lastly,
serotonin-3.
That's going to
be present in the
intestines and in the
chemo trigger zone.
And that can increase the
risk of nausea
and vomiting.
So something like
ondansetron, which
blocks, is a used anti
-emetic drug. Okay,
so I will not test
you. You don't have
to memorize this
chart, but this is
just to try to introduce
the topic about
serotonin receptors
and their action.
So here are the SSRIs.
There's six of them.
They're all available
generically.
The first was
fluvoxamine,
which is known as Luvox,
but fluoxetine,
Prozac, is the one
that's probably
the most popular
because it has the
longest half-life.
Paroxetine, the peas,
should not be
used in pregnancy.
And the reason being
that they see more
cardiac abnormalities
in those babies born to
mothers who took this
drug in pregnancy.
And then the last three
are the newer drugs.
They have an enhanced
bioavailability
where most of them can
be used once a day.
They also, the other
point is that these
three have the least
drug interactions.
But I will say
that citalopram
does raise the
QT interval.
This is one that's
sometimes used in
elderly patients
who are in fact, um,
have depression,
whether it's due to
major depressive
disorder or they have,
um, AD or PD. So it
may be important that
you do checks of
the QT interval. And
the other thing is
that this is another
like thing to know
is that citalopram
is made in 10, 20
and 40 milligrams.
If you're over 65,
you cannot go over
the 20 milligrams
because the degree
of QT interval being
raised is going
to be greater in
that population.
So the SSRI is just
like the name says,
selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors. So here
we're just focusing
on serotonin. We're
going to be affecting the
serotonin transporter.
So if you are affecting
its reuptake, that
means more serotonin is
going to be available
to bind to the
postsynaptic receptors.
They're used for many,
many types of conditions.
OCD, they can be used
in panic disorder,
bulimia, anorexia,
post-traumatic stress
disorder, and premenstrual
dysphoric disorder.
So those are people
that right before they
menstruate, they feel
a change in mood.
Remember, with panic
disorder, you can
start this
medication, but as I
mentioned, there's
going to be a lag before
you get efficacy.
So that's where if
the patient was
having an acute panic
attack, you may
want to give them
initially some dose,
small dose of benzos.
And then once the SSRI
starts to be effective,
then you would wean
them off the benzo.
So here's the thing.
When you compare
the tricyclics
to this group, there's no
blockade of the
other receptors.
And that is important
because if you
were to overdose in
an SSRI, you would
not have the
autonomic instability
that you would with
the tricyclics.
And that's going to
include, as I mentioned,
less effects on
cardiotoxicity and less
effects on developing
convulsions and seizures.
But some things we
have to consider,
the adverse
effects. Number one,
SSRIs can cause
headache, And that's
because with these
medications, there
may be some degree
of dilation that
can happen in the
cerebral vessels.
And if dilation
happens, you're
more prone to a headache.
Okay, so that's
number one.
Nausea and vomiting
may be due to the fact
that initially they can
activate the serotonin
3 receptors and those
are present in the
chemo trigger zone
and in the intestines.
There is something
called discontinuation
syndrome, that if you
stop the medication
abruptly, you may be
prone to a rebound.
Anxiety, they may
feel tingling,
they may have dizziness.
So the important
thing is to
taper the dose
off. So if they
were taking, say,
40 milligrams,
titrate them down
now. to 30 for a
while, 20, 10 until
they discontinue.
Fluoxetine is the
least because it has
the longest half-life.
So this goes back
to what we talked
about with the opioids
and the benzos. The
longer the half-life,
the less of a
withdrawal. Makes sense.
Bleeding abnormalities.
So here's Here's the
thing of what's
happening.
In the platelets, there
may be an inhibition
of serotonin. And
if that's the case,
there's low serotonin
in the platelet, that's
going to stop aggregation.
Because serotonin
is pretty much needed
for aggregation.
So if not a lot of
serotonin is getting
into that platelet,
what you will
get is probably
more of a bleeding.
And that can
be magnified if
you're giving
this medication,
say, with aspirin
or an NSAID.
The ****** side
effects often can
limit the use of
these medications
is that a couple of
things could be happening.
Number one, there
may be an inhibition
of something called
nitric oxide synthase.
And if that's the case,
you don't make nitric
oxide. And that's not
going to be able to
relax the endothelium
of the smooth muscle.
So if there's no
relaxation there, you're
not going to get
enhanced blood flow. And
that can be one mechanism
for the impotence.
And then the other
thing is, as you raise
serotonin, there may
be some reduction
in dopamine, and that
can stop arousal.
So the way you
can do it is you
can give the lowest
dose possible.
There can be change
that you can give,
like a drug that does
not have reuptake for
serotonin, like
bupropion, and I'll talk
about that in a moment.
or some physicians,
if this is really
bothersome, can
prescribe a phosphodiesterase
5 inhibitor,
something like
sildenafil.
Serotonin syndrome,
again, this could be
an effect if you're
combining one of these
with anything else
that's serotonergic.
Weight gain can
happen and And
that might be due
to the blockade
of the serotonin
2C receptors.
So I mentioned that
before and how the
agonist locasterin was
used for weight loss.
And the drug interactions
are going to be
the most with
fluoxetine and the least
with sertraline, citalopram,
and escitalopram.
So again, these are
the newer drugs.
One thing to note,
and I probably
should have mentioned
it early on, is,
remember when we talk
about depression, it
has to be a loss in
pleasurable activities
for about two weeks,
okay?
Maybe the patient has
insomnia, or maybe they
sleep too much, maybe
they're having changes
in appetite, either
they're increasing,
getting weight gain
or losing weight. But
again, there's certain
criteria, I'm not going
to go through them,
because you need to be
able to distinguish
a time frame because
patients, you know, we
all go through things,
you know, during the
day, the loss of job,
loss of family member.
That doesn't necessarily
say that the patient
has clinical depression.
So make sure that
you understand that
there are ways to go
about diagnosing. Okay.
The next group is
going to be the SNRIs.
And these are very
interesting because they
mimic tricyclics in
that they will block
the reuptake of serotonin
and norepinephrine.
But the good thing
about them is
that they don't affect
the other receptors.
So there's not going
to be any alpha block
or muscarinic block
or histamine block.
They can be used
for depression. They
have not been surpassed
by SSRIs. that's
going to be has been
for a while the drug
of choice for major
depression and other
disorders but what is
good about these is
that they can be used
for fibromyalgia or
neuropathic pain and
i think i did mention
that when we talked
about the tricyclics
like amitriptyline
can also be used for
neuropathic pain. And
that's because these
drugs, what they can
do is they decrease
pain signaling.
Here we have a
couple of them,
duloxetine, venlafaxine,
despenlafaxine.
And although, as I
said, they can be
used for pain, and
that's a good thing,
it's usually pain
with depression,
because, as I said,
the main drugs for
depression are still
going to be SSRIs.
So bupropion is going
to spare the serotonin.
These are going to
be specific reuptake
inhibitors of dopamine
and norepinephrine.
There's also not
going to be much of an
effect on the muscarinic
and H1 receptors.
And because it's
not affecting
serotonin, you're
not going to have any
effects really on
****** dysfunction.
So this can be an
option for those
patients that
are having these
effects with,
say, fluoxetine.
The other thing that's
special about this
medication is that it
is a 2D6 inhibitor.
So what does that
mean? Well, in 2022,
there was a medication
approved that included
bupropion and
dextromethorphan. And
this is also another
option for depression.
So the question is, you
know, why dextromethorphan?
So going back to
when we discussed
dextromethorphan, we
know it as a cough
suppressant. But remember,
its mechanism was
number one, it was an
NMDA receptor antagonist.
So you'll see by
the end when I talk
about esketamine what
that means. And it also
is a serotonin reuptake
inhibitor. And that's
why dextromethorphan
can cause serotonin
syndrome when combined
with, say, an SSRI.
The principle is
that by giving
dextromethorphan with
bupropion, bupropion
inhibits the metabolism
of 2D6, which is
a substrate for
dextromethorphan. So
what you're doing is
you're raising the
levels of
dextromethorphan, and that
provides an added
antidepressant effect.
another medication
that we should
have reviewed and
we did in opioids
was the weight loss
drug naltrexone
and bupropion so
what happens here is
that there is in
the hypothalamus a
specific i would
say protein known
as propiomelanocortin
and that is
going to be increased
by bupropion.
And when you increase
POMC, and that was
one of the slides in
the opioid lecture, now
that I'm remembering.
When you increase
that, that's going to
decrease appetite, and
that's a good thing.
But the one thing
to know is that when
that is stimulated, it
also increases beta
endorphins, and that
can shut down this
weight loss mechanism.
So by giving naltrexone,
you will block this
beta endorphin and
you enhance the POMC.
And the other thing
is just remember,
naltrexone, remember,
by decreasing the
reward, which is
dopamine, that can also
help patients that
are craving food.
Bupropion cannot be
given to bulimics
because when you
are bulimic and
you are vomiting
much, you're thinking
now you're losing
electrolytes.
And because of that,
that can actually reduce
the seizure threshold.
So the patients
that are bulimic and
take this medication
are going to be prone
to have more seizures.
Something special
about bupropion, it
is a non-competitive
nicotinic receptor
antagonist. So this
medication can be
given to patients
that are depressed
and maybe are trying
to stop smoking,
smoking cessation.
There is another
one that's a partial
agonist of the nicotinic
receptor, and that's
verenocline. And
this is a good one
because it would block
the nicotinic receptor,
but there is some
release of nicotine
where the patient
is not going to have
too much of a craving
or withdrawal so
this one is good because
you don't need to
give like say patches
or lozenges with
with verinicline
with um bupropion you
may need to do that
because the patients
can still have some
cravings for nicotine
the one thing about
verinicline and again
this is the mechanism
bupropion is that in the
past some people have
complained that when
they took Chantix,
they got this really
feeling of waking up and
sleepwalking, and there
was some increased
risk of suicide. Since
then, it's been taken
off the black box,
warning, but it's just
something to consider.
Now we have something,
mirtazapine,
And this is what
we call a TICA.
It's a tetracyclic
antidepressant.
It's going to
block alpha-2.
And by blocking
alpha-2, think about
clonidine. It's going
to be the opposite. If
you're blocking alpha
-2 presynaptically,
you're increasing
your sympathomimetics.
So you're increasing
norepinephrine.
So that is going
to make the
patient now feel
better because
there's more
norepinephrine there.
And I explained
clonidine,
which is an
alpha-2 agonist.
In the earlier
slide, I said that
patients would
become more depressed
if they were taking
clonidine because
that's shutting
down sympathetics.
This is the opposite.
It's going to raise.
A couple of things.
The H1 block is going
to cause sedation, and
it's also going to
cause the weight gain.
So the weight gain,
again, that has
to do with the fact
that H1 blockade,
and this is, again,
we're talking about
lipophilicity,
getting through the
blood-brain barrier.
You're going to increase
fat accumulation,
and you're going
to increase the AMP
kinase signal, which
increases appetite.
And in addition, it also
blocks the serotonin
2C receptors. So, two
together is going to
cause a significant
amount of weight gain.
So, if somebody
has an eating
disorder, this might
be a good option
if you did not
want to do an SSRI.
When you block the
serotonin 2A receptors,
you are going to see
less ****** dysfunction.
Okay, so it's
going to be kind
of like the
opposite of an SSRI.
Okay, you're blocking
serotonin in this case.
Blockade of the serotonin
-3, that's going to
be good because it's
not going to cause the
patient to be nauseous,
unlike the SSRIs.
And then there's
going to be some
stimulation, some agonism
at the serotonin-1A.
Kind of mimics
buspirone, so this
can help patients
that have anxiety.
Continuing on, we
have trazodone.
This is called
a SARI So it's
a serotonin
reuptake inhibitor
And it's also
a blocker of
serotonin 2A So it
has two functions
It has a good degree
of H1 block And
that's why in the
sedative hypnotic lectures
I said trazodone
could be used for
inducing sleep Due to
that H1 block But it
also causes a degree
of alpha-1 block.
And alpha-1
block is going to
result in smooth
muscle relaxation.
And aside from
the orthostasis
that you might expect,
this can also increase
blood flow. and
that can cause something
called priapism
and the priapism is
is basically when
somebody experiences
an ******** that
lasts a long time
this can be a really
dangerous situation
usually patients have
to go to the ed to
manage this effect
so this is a big
warning with trazodone.
And that's due to the
significant
alpha-1 blockade.
If you give a CYP3A4
inhibitor like
grapefruit juice,
it's going to
increase the levels
of this drug.
Nifazodone has
similar mechanism like
trazodone, but it's
not given as much
anymore because it's
highly hepatotoxic.
Relazodone has the
same mechanism,
but it's also a
partial serotonin 1A
agonist. So again,
with relazodone,
I would also be
mindful that this is
going to be a good
one for anxiety.
Rodeoxetine has the
same mechanism as
relazodone, the partial
serotonin 1A agonism,
and the reuptake
inhibitor and blockade,
but it also inhibits
norepinephrine reuptake.
okay so you start
to see with a lot of
these medications that
they start increasing
their mechanisms with
different receptor
blockades the other
thing to know is that
when you have more
serotonin block and
partial serotonin 1a
agonism you may have less
effects here on on
Weight gain as well.
Geperone sounds
like buspirone. And
that's a good thing
because it does
have agonism,
again, at the
serotonin 1A receptors.
It's selective.
It's not partial.
What distinguishes
it from buspirone
is that it binds
less to dopamine.
Again, less weight gain
and ****** dysfunction
because there's
not reuptake,
inhibition of serotonin.
It's used for
major depressive
disorder and it's
dosed once a day.
And the adverse effects
can include dizziness,
headache, and that
can be due somewhat
to the serotonin
receptors, especially if
we were talking about
the 1D, 1B receptors.
And it can also
increase QT prolongation
and that has to
do with blockade
of the potassium
channels of the heart
and that increases
repolarization.
Brixanilone is a
newer class of drug.
It is a derivative
of progesterone.
it's a positive
modulator of GABA because
it modulates the
GABA-A receptors both
pre- and post
-synaptically so that's
going to enhance
hyperpolarization which is
due to the chloride
ion being negative
and it acts
rather quickly
and it lasts for 30 days
this is the one
that they used in
postpartum
depression And this
particular formulation
has to be given
through a health
care facility.
It has to go through
risk evaluation
and mitigation
strategy, REMS.
So you have to
meet the criteria.
You have to agree
to have this done
in a facility.
You have to be
monitored for
sedation and for mood.
There is a newer one
called Zor-Nolone.
this one is given
****** so it does not
need REMS it does
not need you to be in
a facility you can
take it on your own
but one thing that
you have to understand
is you're probably
going to have to sign
papers that you
are not going to be
driving and you're
aware of the sedative
effects especially if
you have to be at home
and take care of the
children the baby
so now we shift into
bipolar and there's
going to be two
classifications bipolar one
this means that the
person had one manic
episode and it lasted
for at least seven days
then they go in the low
zone or the depressive
phase for for two
weeks bipolar two is
considered to be more
depressive than manic.
And if they do
get episodes of
hypomania,
they're more mild.
So I like to say
that Bipolar I, we're
considering more
manic. Bipolar
II, more depressive
versus the other.
You're going to
hear people saying
that they are
considered to be
rapid cyclers. This
is where they have
four or more
episodes in a year.
And the
treatments include
the following, lithium,
valproate, carbamazepine,
lamotrigine,
which are considered
to be anti-epileptics.
And you could also
give atypicals.
And as I
mentioned, I'll do
atypicals in the
next lecture as well.
So lithium is
going to block IP3.
Basically you're
thinking about the
GQ mechanism and
protein kinase C.
By blocking that,
you're going to
modulate neurotransmitters,
especially
excessive dopamine
and glutamate, which
is the likely cause
of manic episodes.
Lithium, however,
has a couple
of things that
you need to know.
First of all, it has
a narrow therapeutic
index, and this
means that the toxic
and the therapeutic
dose are very close.
This is given as 300
milligram capsules.
So 300 milligrams, the
maximum just for you
to understand is 1
,200 milligrams a day.
They become toxic at
15 milligrams, 1,500
milligrams. And that
just is one extra
300 milligram capsule.
So if they didn't
remember taking their
last dose and they took
another one, they
can go into toxicity.
So this has to be
carefully administered,
and the patient has
to understand that.
The other thing
is that lithium
has various drug
interactions.
Number one,
thiazides, because
what ends up
happening is that
thiazides are
used as diuretics.
They get rid of
sodium and water.
But then later on,
the feedback is
that you recover
more sodium in
the proximal tubule.
When that happens,
you also will
recover lithium.
And that creates
toxicity. So you
need to be very
mindful when
giving these drugs
with diuretics.
ACE inhibitors
and NSAIDs.
NSAIDs will block in the
afferent arterial
of the kidney.
When that's
blocked and you
decrease prostaglandins,
you decrease
glomerular
filtration rate.
With ACE inhibitors,
and I like to
think of ACE being
with an E, ACE
inhibitors block the
efferent arteriole.
If you block
angiotensin II in the
efferent, you're also
going to decrease
GFR, glomerular
filtration rate.
And that means now
that you're not going
to be able to
excrete your lithium.
You're going to
enhance reabsorption.
So when lithium is
given with any of these
medications, you
need to be mindful of
the dose. And I think
when you get to renal
next fall, you'll
understand this more.
Some of the adverse
effects can be tremors.
beta blockers may
help and that might
be due to now
decreasing some of the
perhaps norepinephrine
that might
be causing some
of that tremor
leukocytosis means
that in the white blood
cells there might be a
burst it's not related
to infection it just
might be an effect of
the medication that
can kind of point to
you that initially they
started lithium patients
will experience
polyuria and polydipsia
where they're very
thirsty and they complain
of urinating a lot
and this can be
especially true if
they are if it's a hot
summer day and they're
dehydrated and what
this translates into
is the loss of adh
and if you lose adh
that means you're not
getting aquaporins in
the collecting duct
and that will allow
lots of water to be
coming out in the
urine water loss that
is sometimes called
nephrogenic diabetes
and sympathis how you
manage that is that
in the collecting duct
you give amelioride,
and that is considered
to be a sodium
channel blocker in
the collecting duct.
Hypothyroidism, I'll
speak about in a moment.
And then the other thing
is that in pregnancy,
we do not give lithium
because lithium
can cause something
known as Epstein anomaly.
where the tricuspid
valve is displaced
to the right ventricle.
When the baby
is born, they're
going to be hypoxic.
They're going to be
very cyanotic. And the
way we manage that
is by giving surgery,
basically. It has to be
fixed. So that's just
a little bit about the
theme in pregnancy.
so here we are again
explaining lithium
and how it follows
more of a GQ mechanism
so as you can see
you're going to
decrease protein lipase
C decreasing DAG and
IP3 and that's going
to shut down excessive
release of
neurotransmitters that
might be involved in
the bipolar disorder
I'm not going to
have you responsible
for this right now
because we'll go
through this in
thyroid but understand
that thyroid hormone
is formed in the
thyroid gland through
various mechanisms
and enzymes
involved but before
thyroid hormone can
get into the blood
it needs to come out
of a storage protein
and that is known
as proteolysis.
Lithium has been shown
to block proteolysis
and that would mean
there's going to be less
circulating thyroid
hormone in the blood.
That leads to hypothyroidism.
So the patient
now will experience
a decrease in heart
rate. There'll be cold,
pale, hair falling,
brittle nails. And
I will say that in
patients that I have
dispensed lithium to,
in about a year, they
usually will need
to get Synthroid,
which is a thyroid
replacement. So the
idea of hypothyroidism
and lithium is a
very real concept,
both for your exam
and clinically.
The next thing is
going to be valproate.
and melproate is an
anti-epileptic drug.
It's considered to
be broad spectrum and
that means it can take
care of various types
of seizures because
of its mechanism.
It blocks sodium channels
and type T calcium
channels, so that
might be good for
absons, the T-type.
It decreases glutamate
at NMDA receptors. it
increases GABA action
and synthesis and
blocks the degradation
of GABA. So putting
this all together,
you can see that the
possibility of it helping
stabilize mood is
going to be strong.
So in those patients
that cannot take
lithium, this would
be another option. The
only thing is valproate
is not void of
adverse effects.
Number one, it can
cause something called
valproate syndrome,
where the baby will
be born with spinal
bifida and neural
tube defects, and
that has to do with
the fact that valproate
can affect the
metabolism of folate.
Weight gain may
be due to the fact
that you may stimulate
insulin release,
and that will
promote fat storage.
The effects on the
liver is critical,
where number one,
you're going to get an
inhibition in fatty
acid beta-oxidation.
And when that
happens, if we're
talking about the
mitochondria, there's
going to be a decrease
in ATP production.
The other thing is that
its metabolite is toxic
and it can damage
the hepatocytes.
So valproate,
you need to make
sure you look at
the liver function
before starting
this medication.
And the other thing
is that if the patient
presents with the
right upper quadrant
pain or yellowing of
the eyes or the skin,
that you check that
as well. And then
valproate is another
inhibitor of 2D6 and 3A4.
Carbamazepine blocks
sodium channels.
It's used for tonic
-clonic, trigeminal,
and also bipolar
disease because, in
essence, there's also
another mechanism that
it blocks the
norepinephrine reuptake.
But carbamazepine
can cause certain
effects as well. It
can cause drowsiness,
ataxia, diplopia,
which is double vision.
It causes the opposite
of what lithium
causes. As I mentioned
with lithium we were
talking about in
decreasing ADH. With
this it's going to
be a syndrome of
inappropriate ADH. So
now the patient is going
to have water
intoxication. So they're
going to have more
of now a retention of
water and that's going
to cause something
called hyponatremia
because now there's
a lot more fluids
in your system and
it's diluting. So your
sodium will be low.
Aplastic anemia
means that there's
going to be a lack of
production of cells,
blood cells from
the bone marrow.
And that may
be due to toxic
metabolites of
carbamazepine,
causing damage to
the stem cells.
With teratogenicity,
it could
be, again, a
folate story.
Steven Johnson
syndrome is going
to be specific
to those people
who have an HLA
-B1502 allele.
That tends to happen
in those people that
are descendants of
East Asia, where if
they should develop
a rash when taking
carbamazepine initially,
they need to stop the
medication and consult
their physician.
And then just
like phenyton and
phenobarbital,
rifampin, grizeofolvin,
carbamazepine is an
inducer of SIP. So if
you were taking
carbamazepine with, say,
an oral contraceptive,
contraceptive,
there's a chance that
the oral contraceptive
would have a lower
plasma concentration,
and that can lead
to pregnancy.
Lamotrigine blocks GABA.
It actually, it blocks
the sodium channels,
just like carbamazepine.
I'm sorry.
It potentiates GABA,
but it blocks glutamate.
So you can see
that it's used for
many types of
seizures and bipolar.
Aside from the fact
that it causes sedation,
there can be a
reactive sulfate that
forms and that's
going to bind to the
T cells and that can
lead to an antegetic
response and that can
manifest as a rash
and worst case
scenario, that can be
Steven Johnson syndrome,
kind of like what
you see with
sulfonamide medications.
So atypical
antipsychotics will
be covered again
in the next
lecture. So take
it as a first pass.
These are second
generation where the
blockade of dopamine
is not as strong
as serotonin. And
because of that,
you're not going to
have much of a problem
in the nigrostriadium,
so there's
going to be less
Parkinson-like effects.
In the tubular
infundibular area, there's
not going to be much
of a block there
either, so that means
patients are not going
to get much of an
increase in prolactin.
But one of the things
that this can do,
and which helps even
in mood disorder,
is that many of
them can actually
increase dopamine release
in the mesocortical
area. And in the
mesocortical area,
if you're increasing
dopamine there,
that helps with
the whole idea of
feeling apathetic,
feeling low.
Those are called
negative symptoms.
And then on the flip
side, and this is
going to apply more
to schizophrenia,
there is some reduction
of dopamine in the
mesolimbic area. And
that's good because in
the mesolimbic area,
that's where you're
getting more of the
positive symptoms, the
person being delusional
and hallucinating.
So that I will bring up
again in the
next lecture.
A couple of things
is all of these will
prolong the QT
interval. So just like
citalopram, you
would have to do some
EKG with this, both
initially and
periodically.
The other thing is that
there is some degree
of weight gain.
Again, that's because
you're blocking the
serotonin 2C receptors.
Some of these drugs
will also block H1 and
you'll see in a moment
and that's going
to change ultimately
metabolism and that can
raise both sugar and
cholesterol levels.
The following ones
that I'll talk
about are approved
for mania.
So Aripiprazole,
it's a partial D2
and serotonin 1A
agonist and it also
blocks the serotonin
2A receptors.
So here you'll see that
with the 1A agonism,
that can help with
some of the anxiety
or irritability that
people can have.
But in the partial D2,
understand that
again, when we're
talking about the
mesolimbic area,
you're going to
get a reduction in
dopamine and that's
going to help
some of the
manic episodes
that patients will have.
But then on the flip
side in the mesocortical
area it's going to
increase dopamine
being a partial agonist.
So block, enhance
and this enhancement
helps with some of the
anxiety, some of the
depressive symptoms.
So this is the reason
why arepiprazole
is used in
several types of
conditions, bipolar,
schizophrenia,
Tourette's,
and some of the
irritability that
happens with autism.
Tourette's I'll
talk about in
the next lecture.
Classically, Tourette's
has been treated
with pimizide, which is
a D2 blocker, but since
there's adverse effects
with the D2 blockers,
and you'll see in the
next lecture, it's
widely being replaced
with arepiprazole.
And Tourette's
means that there's
an imbalance of
dopamine, and the
patient, which is
usually a pediatric
patient, has
tics that happen.
Motor tics where they'll
move involuntarily,
or they'll have
voice tics where
they'll blurt something
out unexpectedly.
This medication
is a serotonin 2C
agonist, which is a
good thing because
this one won't
show as much weight
gain as the other
atypicals. And then,
of course, it's a
substrate for SIP.
Olanzapine.
This is the one with
the most weight gain.
Couple of
things about it.
It has significant
H1 block, so the
sedation and the
weight gain are
going to be a lot
more prominent.
And it's also approved in
combination with
fluoxetine for mania.
So it's given
with an SSRI.
Quetiapine is a
D2 blocker, but it
binds to the
receptor for a short
period of time.
So it doesn't bind
enough to cause
the EPS symptoms.
It has minimal muscarinic
block, but it has
a significant degree
of sedation because it
blocks H1 and it also
can cause orthostatic
hypotension because
of alpha 1 block. This
can sometimes be used
for aggressiveness in
those that have
neurodegenerative disorders.
And the thing that
makes it nice is because
there's no muscarinic
block and those
patients are going to
be more susceptible to
cognition problems
with muscarinic block,
but you still got to
remember that they
can get sedated and
they can get alpha-1
block, which can cause
postural hypotension.
Rispidone increases
prolactin.
It has a significant
degree in H1 block,
so it causes a good
amount of weight
gain, which can
increase cholesterol and
blood sugar and it
also has alpha 1
block so there's going
to be hypotension
Ziprocidone has the
same it's a serotonin 2A
antagonist but it
blocks serotonin and
norepinephrine reuptake
same thing with the H1
block and alpha 1 block
but it also can cause
a skin reaction that
is reminiscent of
getting like a rash and
that, again, we would
be concerned with
Stephen Johnson syndrome.
And then
caraprazine is both
a partial agonist
of D2 and D3
and it's also a
serotonin 1A agonist.
So again, it can
help with some of the
anxiety that these
patients may have.
Since it's partial for
D2 and D3, there can
be some akathisia.
And akathisia, I'll
explain again in the
next lecture, has to do
with the fact that
the patient has these
involuntary movements.
They're very restless.
Probably the classic
name is restless
legs, and that's
due to dopamine.
luma teperone is a
medication that came
out not too long ago
and this drug focuses
mostly on glutamate
okay and this is
important to understand
because when there's a
dysfunction of the
nmda receptor there's
going to be a couple
of things happening
number one there's
going to be lowered
glutamic transmission,
and that lower glutamate
is going to produce
negative symptoms.
Inactivity,
they're going to be
more socially
withdrawn, apathetic.
The other thing is
that with lowered
GABA that may
occur with this, it
promotes dopamine,
and that can yield
some of the positive
symptoms that
can be delusional,
hallucinations.
So this medication
kind of balances
out the glutamate
story because it
actually enhances
NMDA receptors.
So if you enhance NMDA
receptors and their
activity, you actually
can get some release
of glutamate. and some
release of glutamate
is important when
we're talking about
patients that have
these type of disorders.
So lumeteperone
was approved for
schizophrenia,
major depression
disorder, and
bipolar 1 and 2.
Aside from the
glutamate, it's a
serotonin 2A
receptor blocker, and
it has a binding
of 60 times greater
than the dopamine
2 receptors.
And the other
thing is that it
does balance out
dopamine as well.
With dopamine, it
will be an agonist
presynaptically, so
there's going to be
some release, but
postsynaptically, it's
going to block. So
in other words, by
balancing, you're
just getting the right
amount of dopamine
that you need. So
there's three transmitters
here with this
drug. Very new,
definitely more pricey.
There's glutamate,
serotonin, and dopamine
that are involved
with this medication.
And then lastly is
esketamine. This is the
S-enantiomer of
ketamine. And this is
important, because
the mechanism, number
one, as you can see,
the drug will bind, and
that will lead to a
surge of glutamate.
Okay?
Then, the next
thing, as you can
see, you're increasing
glutamate, and
that activates the
AMPA receptors.
Okay?
Next, you're
getting an increase
of brain-derived
nutrietic factor.
And then lastly, that
increases protein
synthesis and increase
in synaptogenesis.
So let's put this
now into things
we can understand.
This drug is
not going to be
used every day.
This is for
people that have
treatment-resistant
depression.
Those patients
that might be at
a great risk of
becoming suicidal
Mechanism is that it
blocks the NMDA receptor
And since you're
blocking glutamate
You're blocking that
receptor You're going
to increase initially
glutamine release Since
you're blocking the
receptors And that
increase in glutamate
at that moment Is giving
that patient relief
against their depression
you're also going to
increase BDNF and I
explained probably in
the Parkinson's lecture
in the AD lecture that
this is actually a
good thing because you're
increasing plasticity
you're increasing
the growth of neurons
and that in essence
helps with cognition
and patients that
are depressed
will sometimes
complain that they
feel like they're
in a brain fog
but a couple of
things about this one
this is not an everyday
drug as mentioned
you have to administer
this in a supervised
clinical setting
the patient has to
be in this place for
about two hours why
because the patient
can get number one
severe sedation so
make sure you have
somebody to drive
you home dissociative
effects where they
could become almost like
how do i say um that
they're awake but
they're like kind of
seeing things this is
what happens when people
use *** or ketamine
they almost are awake
but they're telling
you that they see um
spiders and things of
that nature so you
have to monitor for
those type of effects
and then of course since
it's an enantiomer
of ketamine a drug
that's illicit you can
get ***** liability.
So usually what
will happen with
this, they will come
into the facility
twice a week. I believe
it might be for a
few weeks. And then after
the patient adjusts,
they will come in
for once a week. And
in addition, they'll
be taking another oral
antidepressant on
the outpatient.
Okay, so that's a little
bit about esketamine.
It's very, very
interesting, not just the
fact that it has to be
so critically monitored
in a facility. It's
given intranasally.
So in summary, I know
that this was a lot,
and I will do a question
review. Some of this
will be reviewed in
the next lecture, so
that might be a good
thing, but I advise you
to go through the
question review and some
of the questions that
I included in the um,
in the handout,
because as I said, this
is really high yield,
not just for, um,
exams,
but for practice,
even if you're not
a psychiatrist and
you're doing internal
medicine or PEDS,
there might be a
time where your
patients are going to
be using these
medications and you have
to recognize some
of the adverse
effects. So thank you
for your attention.
Um, let me know
if there's any
questions and
I'll see you soon.